right
morning everyone welcome to
baby planning committee um i will now
hand over to the governance officer to
read out the domestic arrangements and
the fire regulations
thank you claire
please ensure that you maintain safer
distancing excuse me from all other
persons whilst in the chamber and in the
communion areas please ensure that you
wear a face covering at all times unless
you were sitting down
or if you were exempt from doing so and
that you use the hand sanitizer and
wipes provided please ensure that
microphones are turned off when not in
use please do not interrupt other
speakers or hold separate conversations
whilst others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave please
ensure your mobile phones are on silent
or switched off
we will be using the e-voting for this
meeting on the moderngov app so please
members make sure they are logged in and
ready to use the app
if you hear the fire alarm leave the
building immediately fire fire exit and
make your way to the assembly point
which is ipswich town football ground
follow the signs directing you to the
fire exit at each end of the floor
do not enter the atrium if you are in
the atrium at the time of the alarm
follow the signs to the nearest fire
exit use the stairs not the lifts and do
not re-enter the building until you're
told it's safe to do so
i would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet and will be capable of
repeated viewing the whole of the
meeting will be recorded except where
there are confidential or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to be recorded
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those sound recordings
for webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph or
record this broadcast this meeting when
the public and the press are not
lawfully excluded
thank you chair
officer is mark russell uh our legal
advisor ian depray
our case officers elizabeth flood and
rose
fine
apologies for absence and substitutions
okay
declarations of interest are there any
to declare
no thank you
oh yes
councillors
thank you chair and just to say that my
sister-in-law is the actual manager of
shotley marina so obviously no no
i just need to tell you thank
you uh indeed chairman mr councillor air
spoke to me briefly before the meeting
it's a straightforward non-pecuniary
interest that
happened to having a family member not a
close family member linked in that way
that's properly declared we can carry on
without worries okay thank you any
others
no right
moving on have you all received the
minutes of the last meeting
are there any points of accuracy in the
minutes that someone would like changed
if not can i have a proposal thank you
adrian councillor osborne a seconder
councillor beer thank you
thank you chair members if you go to the
plus sign in the top right hand corner
of your app
and
select attendance and voting this vote
should now be in progress
okay
council of beer can i take your vote
please thank you
thank you members yeah that's 10 votes
for that's unanimous thank you very much
didn't count me no idea
receive notification petitions in
accordance with the council's petition
scheme
received
site
inspections we have a request for a site
visit which will be presented by rose
walton
rose would you like to carry on please
thank you um good morning chair good
morning members
a site visit has been requested for this
site
which is the land south of honeysuckle
cottage in holbrook
the application is hybrid seeking
outline permission for the erection of
four self-built dwellings with all
matters reserved other than access
and full planning permission for the
erection of four two-bedroom dwellings
with associated landscaping
vehicle access of piums lane and
pedestrian access to church hill
the site visit has been requested
because there is concern regarding the
rural character of hyams lane
impact to the aomb
highway safety and use as well as
contrary to policies within the core
strategy
and policies within the baby local plan
and mppf there's also concern raised
regarding the proximity of the fire
station and its activity as well as
still monies
next slide please emily
this is the site highlighted in yellow
for you
with the fire station adjacent on the
right hand side there
next slide please
this is the village of holbrook the site
is highlighted by the yellow star
this just shows you the site's proximity
to the rest of the village
next slide please
just for a bit of context this is the
proposed layout
you can see the proposed vehicle access
on the south
side of the site off of hines lane and
the
pedestrian access on the northeast side
adjacent to jubilee house at the top
there
next slide please
starting off with some photos on the
site itself
the image on the left hand side shows
where i was approximately standing when
the photo was taken
which is highlighted by the yellow star
and the direction of the photo was taken
in
so this photo was taken looking north
into the site
you can see the fire station drill tower
on the right hand side there
next slide please
this is another image
from within the site
it's looking towards the western
boundary
which is natural hedgerow and trees next
slide please
this photo is taken slightly further
into the site looking towards the
eastern boundary towards the fire
station
unfortunately i wasn't able to travel
any deeper into the site as you can see
it's heavily overgrown with brambles and
these photos are up to date taken on
sunday the 17th of october
next slide please
this photo shows the view from the
proposed access site down onto hyams
lane you can see the existing dwellings
on the south side of the road just there
next slide please
this is a view looking eastwards on
hyams lane you can see the proposed
vehicle access site on the left hand
side there
next slide
please this is a view standing from on
highlands lane looking into the site
from the proposed vehicle access site
and with the you can see the drill tower
there
next slide please
this is a view looking west on hinds
lane you can see the proposed vehicle
access site on the right hand side there
next lie please
and this is a view looking
from further up hymes lane looking west
you can see part of an existing dwelling
on the south side of hines lane
next slide please
this is a view looking
west down hines lane it's from the
junction between hines lane and
churchill
you can see
how it uh turns into a single lane road
just a bit further into the road
next slide please
this is a view looking
west
down hiams lane
from churchill
next slide please
this is a view looking towards
the drill tower
from the junction between hind lane and
churchill
and next slide please
and this is a view from
churchill looking at the proposed
location of the pedestrian access
the plant life and tree area that you
can see there would be removed to make
way for the pedestrian access
next slide please
and this is a view from a little further
up church hill looking south towards the
proposed pedestrian access site and
which is where that greenery is that you
can see which is proposed to be removed
and i think that's
yeah i think just to check the next
slide
yeah
thank you
the opposite
um thank you chair
uh morning roses
don't make me chuckle
um sorry um rose
if we're being asked to um to go on site
visit for this i know there's four
dwellings so that would normally be
officer delegation so just
there it is well thank you thank you
very much
so does that suggest then that there's
there's been a call in full referral and
if so what's the policy reason for that
please
uh this application wasn't called into
committee by a ward member and it was
under
phil's um
decision that it's controversial it's
received a number of objections from
local
residents council parker as he got in
first has asked my question so i'm
really um i haven't got one
uh well yes that was the same question
thank you again for the part i want to
know who called
i've got different questions
um
the members talking about four houses
but from what i could gather from what
you're talking about there there's four
self builds and four with full
permission so that's eight houses in
total yes that's right it's a hybrid
application
so there's eight houses not four on the
side
okay
any other questions
thank you mr chairman yes it's not a
question it's i would propose that we do
have a site visit to this
obviously from the uh
undulations of the
the pictures we've seen the undulations
in there and the highways issues uh i
think we should be there to have a look
at it
thank you councilman
do you have a secondary
council clarion
thank you chair um yes i second
councillor osborne suggestion as a child
who grew up there
i know the area very well and i fully
endorse a site visit thank you
councilman
just make a comment chair
um
my request the reason my request was
more to do with the width of the country
lane
and the access of
i did
chairman if i may i think if i've
understood correctly mr ispell thinks it
should come to this committee anyway but
the council of mclaren has asked for a
astrocyte businesses
mr chairman sorry
that was my question who actually called
for it um i mean i'm more than happy if
it was um the chief planning that um but
i'm even more happier that it was the
local member so i do think it's
important we do know that thank you
i think what happened is one got in
before the other
they both started the process at the
same time
council
yes mr chairman um based on what the the
officer said about her difficulty in
getting onto this any further onto the
site than where she took the photographs
from and the excellent range of
photographs that she's taken showing the
i think highways issues and access
problems uh quite quite succinctly so i
don't know that there's any need for us
to go out there when all we're going to
do is to stand where those photographs
were taken and see the same thing
thank you kevin any other comment from
anyone
councillor busby
if we go perhaps we could take an hour
turn at the same time taking one
they're working at the same time however
you want to pronounce it
i still can't hear you
there is a controversial planning
application about four miles down the
road that we ought to consider looking
at
air worth
is
would you want to combine them together
well i think we should i say it's only
about two or three miles down the road
and it is even more controversial than
this one
deal with that okay the answer to your
question is no cancel a beer
actually i think council about didn't
hear what was said there it's it's the
owetton site council barrack
the erwinton site was the second site
that's been proposed to visit
um it's a couple of miles away it's
herberton hall is it called next to
erwin
it's not that's not there knowledge
how can we determine it without any
knowledge we can't thank you
um thank you mr chairman could i asked
as the local member called it ian
what the reasons well can you explain
just tell us why you'd like us to go
there i think it's important to know
that
sorry uh jeff thank you i'll address
cancer beer's question um this has been
to plan him came to the planning
department before and was refused
and it's the accent for me the major
difficulty is the access as you can see
it's a one car width
and even at present
people on the left-hand side the
residents people park in their driveways
to allow oncoming traffic so if that had
traffic from a site and the increased
traffic from other houses i think it
would pose a real risk to the safety not
just of um
the people opposite but the
pedestrians a lot of walkers a lot of
dog walkers
and i mean it's a nightmare if there's a
lorry or something going down there so i
think it's very unsafe
thank you
any other comments
if not we have a proposal in the
secondary can i ask you to conduct a
vote please claire
thank you chair
members
that vote is now in progress
council of beer can i take
thank you
sorry members
how are we doing
thank you members chair that's eight
votes four two against and one
abstention so that's carried thank you
can we have a two minute we've just got
to spot something over on the
next wednesday's the date of the site
visit you will prefer it in the
afternoon
does that cause anyone any problems
okay thank you yes please
okay
so that will that cyphers will be two
o'clock next week councilman mclaren
recommends that you park in churchill
and this will come out in the
notification from the government's
office
thank you
now
have a side visit
are we all set right moving on
scheduled planning applications
has been agreed to have a change in the
running order and so we will kick off
with
dc 2004 309 shotley marina
and rose yet again this is your
presentation thank you
thank you
the application we have before us today
is a section 73 to very condition two
approved plans and documents
for b1301384
[Music]
at shotley marina king edward's 7th
drive in shortly
the proposal seeks to amend the layout
and appearance but retain the quantum of
development of 19 residential units and
mix use commercial
space on the ground floor next slide
please
shortly is a hinterland village as
identified within the baba core strategy
which
accommodates some development to help
meet the needs within the village
next slide please
this presentation should be considered
in conjunction with the committee report
which should be available to you
next slide please
next slide please
the proposal concerns the principle of
development the design
impact on heritage assets and ecology
next slide please
next slide please
okay just for a bit of context
this is the built-up area boundary of
shotley gate as currently within the
weber local plan
um
the
site in question is highlighted in
yellow there so you can see
currently is outside of the built-up
area boundary next slide please
this is the built-up area boundary as
proposed and the emerging joint local
plan
so you can see that it is proposed to be
inside the built-up area boundary
it should be noted that the principle of
development
for this application
is already established by grant of
permission of the previous planning
application
therefore the principal one location
won't be considered any further
the key tests are determining the impact
of the alternative architectural
response on the character and appearance
of the area and the setting of the
nearby heritage assets
next slide please
this plan shows the constraints relating
to the site
you can see the purple area which is the
conservation area
the site is highlighted in yellow
the orange marked areas are grade 2
listed heritage assets
and the green area is the aomb boundary
next slide please
just a bit of location context the site
is highlighted by the yellow star
shopli battery adjacent to the north
west
the settlement of shotley gate to the
west
a harridge harbour side to the south and
felix stowe to the east
next slide please
okay just going to take you through the
proposal itself now
this just shows you the site itself
and its proposed layout and this is the
ground floor plan so the hms ganges
museum would be on the left hand side
and the remainder of units to be
commercial space
there will be parking out the front and
rear just as there is currently and as
proposed in the original planning
application
next slide please
this is the first ball plan
seven units of two bedroom flats with
balconies
and lifts
next slide please
a second floor plan
seven units again with two bedrooms the
same as the first floor
next slide please
and this is the third floor plan five
units four of which would have two
bedrooms and one
with three bedrooms that you can see on
the left hand side there
okay next slide please
this is the front elevation which would
face east the top drawing is what is
currently proposed and the bottom
drawing is what has been approved under
the previous application
next slide please
sorry can you just go back one slide
thank you
this is the rear elevation which would
face west again the top drawing is
what's currently proposed and the bottom
is what has previously been approved
next slide please
this is the south facing side elevation
which would have the hms ganges museum
attached to it
the left-hand side drawing is what is
currently proposed and the right hand
side is what has previously been
approved
next slide please
this is the north facing side elevation
again the left-hand side drawing is
what's currently proposed and the right
hand side is what has been approved
previously
next slide please
this just shows you the difference in
heights of what is currently proposed
and what has been approved previously
following discussions with historic
england the originally proposed building
has been reduced in height
and now there is only a 245 millimeter
difference between the proposal and what
has previously been approved
next slide please
okay moving on to heritage
these images show the views of the
proposed and previously approved
buildings from across shortly battery
the drawing on the right hand side shows
where the viewpoint is from
which is highlighted by the yellow star
and where the site is as you can see
there would be
no adverse difference from the
previously approved and the proposed
next slide please
sorry can you just go back one thank you
now this is another view from shortly
battery again and you can see there
would be no adverse difference from the
proposal and previous
next slide please
this is a view from harrage harbourside
and you can see the
previous and the proposal there so there
would be no adverse difference
next slide please
this is a view from langar point
in felix stowe and you can see the
previous and the proposal both there and
as you can see there wouldn't be any
adverse difference
next slide please
both the heritage team and historic
england were consulted during the course
of determination
following engagement with both
consultees the height of the building
was reduced to what you've seen today
and there is no objection raised the
visualizations that you just saw
demonstrate that the revised scheme
would not obscure the horizon when
viewed from the top of shotley battery
would retain views of the battery on the
bluff when looking from harrod
harbourside
and would not impact in any way the view
of the monument from langar point
the heritage consorties agree that the
proposal's impact is negligible and the
level of harm to the significance of the
monument is no longer greater than that
of the consented scheme
next slide please
just a couple of ecology points the
applicant has provided a report of
mitigation measures to any potential
impact to overwintering birds and place
services ecology were consulted during
the course of determination
no objection has been raised subject to
ecological mitigation and enhancement
measures
and a financial contribution towards the
suffolk coast grounds which all can be
dealt with via condition
next slide please
and next slide please uh so negotiations
uh will take place
um of the completion of a section 106
steeda variation
to ensure that obligations attached to
the original application section 106 are
carried forward
next slide please
just take through a couple of photos
this is the site with the access and
parking area you can see the museum
there next slide please
and another shot of the museum
and the commercial space and from
another viewpoint the commercial space
and parking areas next slide please
the recommendation is approval subject
to completion of adida variation thank
you
thank you rose
any questions for the officer councilor
beer
um yes i've got two questions please um
slide 26. can you put that back up um is
that
i believe you said it was the
the site
um
is that the whole site or is that the
size of the
building yes so those are cgi
visualizations showing what the proposed
building would look like from harrage
harbourside
that that is that the whole site of the
building that that sort of line or is
that the site
yes so that shows the site of the
building itself
so the the site is larger than that
yes the the site itself covers the
ground in the building and the second
question then um
the parkin there's 19 dwellings the same
as before
uh how many parking spaces is there is
that the same i can't remember i assume
that was
the same yes as the original application
there's no difference is it 38
i believe that it is 38 but the
agent is is here to answer some more
specific questions
thank you
cancer
thank you chad um is the shipwrecked pub
still there
uh yes it is still there still running
yes thank you
any other questions
come to the buzzword just to clarify on
slide 23 i think do you say that the the
new
[Music]
uh proposal is 245.
or centimeters whatever it is higher or
lower
higher
it is higher yes yeah okay and if you
can go to slide 19.
therefore the same number of units
it almost looks as though the
the proposed one is twice the size of
the previous one
how on earth did we get 19 units in the
in the existing one
chair that those aren't at the same
scale if you look on the top one you can
see the red line which shows the outline
of the
that's that which has been permitted
already
thank you
it just shows the different design but
you're right yeah they're not exactly
the same scale but the red line does
tell the story
parker
yeah sorry chair um and rose i i really
apologize if i'm being more than um dim
here but um
so the key difference is an increase in
the overall building height of 2.4 245
millimeters so that's increasing it um
but it's to be noted that the applicant
originally proposed an overall building
height of 18.65 so is it is it getting
higher does it get
shorter so originally the building
proposed was much higher than what we've
seen today
and
due to engagement with historic england
the the height has been reduced
significantly
any other questions
thanks for borrowing
um
the uh
it doesn't make it clear on these uh on
going back to 19
what happens to the
shocking museum
because the scale is so different
so
does the shot museum looking at the top
one
where's the shopping museum in relation
to that
it's still on the left-hand side there
if i went to the bottom one
the shotgun museum is still in situ as
it is on the bottom
the shotlay museum was always proposed
to be replaced with the original
application
though it's out
it will still be there on the ground
floor level
you see these these illustrations are
not very clear are they because it looks
like if you look at it it looks like
it's been removed
okay okay okay
but is it thank you
can i
ask the question then mr chairman um is
the end bid if you can move your mouse
along and and wiggle over right that's
the museum bit and i got to the top one
is that the bit there is that it still
no
yes that would be where the museum is i
think you need to make this very clear
to us at least
yes the museum is to be replaced
if we could go to slide 20 please
that shows you
the hms ganges museum
there
it was always proposed to be replaced
so to understand this directory what
what we're saying you're saying is that
um on the original
they hadn't yet included a new build for
for the for the shockley museum but it
is included in the later application
uh yes you can see on both drawings
there that the hms ganges museum is
highlighted
okay
so where would that
it's to remain in the same location as
it is currently it won't move it's just
to be replaced
okay am i missing something sorry so is
that is that
hang on a second this is important
so is is it actually a new build in its
lower form
as per the proposed elevation because
i'm sorry i just it's not very clear
what sorry did you counsel about yes
both schemes uh were both new build
everything new build correct rose
oh the old museum buildings you saw on
the other slide was was to be removed
for both schemes
thank you but the the problem is why is
then
on the west elevation previously
approved have we we're showing
that
section to the left
in those pictures because it's not a new
build is it i mean it's grayed out so
that's that's to me it's like an
existing
building
sorry some part of the building and if
we can go back to the first floor plans
yeah the ground floors say existing
retain
yes existing retained some of the
building is to be retained but that's
not the hms ganges museum
that is the existing retail units is it
uh yes that's some retail on the other
side
okay i may i suggest that we we get the
agent to clarify some of these points
when we went after his presentation
everybody's agreeable we'll do that
and any more questions for the officers
if not i'll ask
as there's no parish council or objector
or a supporter i'll ask the agent craig
weston to address us you have three
minutes
thank you chair councilman um yeah the
real purpose for me attending today on
behalf of the applicant shot in marina
uh
was not necessarily to give you a few
minutes of speech because rose's
presentation has quite succinctly
presented the variation
but it has flagged up a couple of um
questions obviously from the committee
so i wanted to be available to answer
those questions
sorry thumbs are a bit death crate do
you mind sorry just talking into the
stick
shout out
i was really here to answer any
questions
hopefully you can all hear
um
and i think i can probably
answer some of those questions by asking
uh
slide 18 to be presented once i finish
which is the front elevation um rose
made a slight error when she's
describing the elevations in the
presentation the front elevation will
show clearly where hms ganges is
and i think that's caused some of the
confusion
but really i'm here to answer any
questions from
the panel
yes i'll put the same question to put to
our offices um
the car parking situation is there uh 38
spaces provided more or less
uh there will be
the same
it'll be the same as what was approved
there's no change to the car parking
provision i can't
unfortunately i can't remember what it
was
[Music]
i don't have that data to hand but it
will be the same there's no change in
respect to parking provision
sorry mr gem we must have it somebody
should bear to tell me the amount of
partners faces i'll look through the
documents uh council miss if i can find
it
thank you mark
any other questions for the agent
council here
yes um
looking at both those both the designs
both the approved and the proposed
ultra uh alternative
um
bearing in mind this is right beside the
sea side
won't burst into song or anything like
that but
which one of those designs is more or
less likely to encourage or discourage
seagulls nesting
because you can't remove them once
they're there
so what proposals are being put in place
to stop them from getting there in the
first place
seagulls are
a force of nature and you can deter
but no there's no
there are certain uh protection measures
you can put on gutters ridges um there's
no difference between the two as to what
would attract more or less there's an
existing building with an existing
roofscape which already
accommodates a number of seagulls
um
i rather like the first design
and looking at the um
well i would um
sort of gets to almost east european
block design for the um
a more up market east european block but
east european government building that
is coming in place is it is this sort of
a cost exercise or is it because on the
design you've definitely got a far more
interesting design than the first one
and design is subjective
of course
it is
and
part of the reason for this variation um
well personally i think that the
the scheme that was originally presented
and has since been reduced
was more attractive
but we've reduced to accommodate um
uh heritage comments
so i had some pitched gables which is
more reflective of the development
completed
uh admiralty pier
well of course i mean you know this is
this is residential development it's not
um bespoke one of homes
um so yes there is always a degree of
viability involved
thank you
yes thank you very much um practical
question occurred to me because i live
in a first floor flat
carrying down my rubbish to the dustbin
will there be any um disposal
waste disposals like they have in other
countries um because it's quite a high
building it's just a practical question
because it can be difficult thank you
uh the
flats are provided with a refuge store
each
group of flats is provided with a lift
which
from recollection wasn't included in the
original so that has been added as a
benefit to all of those units so they
all have
lift access to whichever flat and they
can deposit in a centralized pin store
any other question
thanks beer
mr chairman i i i may be totally wrong
here and i'll i'll wait to be corrected
by yourself um but the peer
um which
uh i'm going from memory when we've been
there on a site inspection is that
receiving any assistance from you as a
developer to improve that because that's
quite near to the side if i remember
rightly is it not
is that part was that part of any of the
original
um agreements that we've done for the
development there
i'm getting a shake from the local
member that no that's not so
i'll just drop the question thank you
thank you
thank you um we talk about the the
height and everything but we haven't
talked about the width is that
is that any longer or is that the same
size thank
you uh yes so as as identified on the
elevations and the plans
uh the overall width of development has
increased
the height
is increased marginally but only in
ridge locations the majority of the
building is
the same or below the approved height
sorry a bit closer
and
the overall width has been increased
to basically accommodate the lifts but
also to provide
wider
individual flats
essentially and as a consequence
that provides additional
ground floor accommodation for
increased amount of commercial activity
and for a larger hms ganges
facility the museum facility
yeah can i yeah thank you for that
because i'm quite impressed that you
have got lifts in because not many flats
do have lifts and so i think that's
quite a good thing
just to comment that thank you thank you
council mclaren thank you chair
um
mr weston who
who were the
um where's the marketplace for the
this uh
these new flats who who is who are you
planning on
um targeting to come into the area i
mean are they local people or
see
people sailors
what's who's the marketplace
yeah well the market is the open market
so whoever wants to buy one of those
homes can they don't necessarily need to
have a local connection
there's no restriction on the previous
approval in that respect
there is a market demand and that is why
the
applicant is bringing this site forward
and is very keen to bring this forward
the
recent development at
shotley lodge and the abnormality pier
completed by the applicant has
demonstrated that need and
that has driven this
slight variation in terms of the
unit layout so we've taken that market
feedback from the previous development
to
guide this variation
so can i ask another question have we
any idea what sort of income is going to
come into
the shortly peninsula as a result of
this
um in short no i can't put a figure to
that yes there will be additional
construction
labor there there will be additional
foot traffic for uh continued use of
shipwreck but it's all
fairly speculative
not a tangible sum that i can put a
number too okay thank you
any other questions counselor busby
i'm still confused as to why
the style change
can you tell me what the driving force
was who said
i don't like what we've proposed we need
to come up with something fresh
well obviously it is partly
construction related in terms of the
cost of construction
it is also a very as i say this is a
variation to the original elevations
that we presented
um we did a series of gables which we
thought sat very comfortably there
but those would have been much higher
and that's what caused the concern from
historic england we therefore adjusted
and took our cue from previous
developments have been completed so the
shortly lodged
and the potential development
include these
mono pitches but also gables
so that's the sort of the drive that's
sort of taking it to this point
what's the difference in
sustainability and
energy conservation
well none is
proposed in in the sense that that's not
part of this application
but the
the development will be constructed to
current standards in terms of building
regulations
which
you know in effect is going to be an
improvement based on
the uh if had it been constructed
under the previous guys
thank you
thank you mr weston
perhaps you'll hang on and see if
there's any more questions for you thank
you very much
i will now ask the ward member council
davis to speak you have five minutes
councillor davis
thank you
i won't take up your whole five minutes
um but
the question i think you're asking is
what does the extra nine and
three-quarter inches actually mean to
the site well i can tell you when the
first proposals came in to to convert
this and permission was granted and a
closer inspection
raised concerns within the hms ganges
museum that the way that the the level
was going to be is that the actual
museum height was going to be lowered
well fine in a lot of ways it has an
awful lot of exhibits but one of the
main exhibits is an eight foot high
um
indian prince head which is the original
hms county's
figurehead so
hms ganges the volunteers really wanted
this to be kept and there are all sorts
of things
coming in and when did this they decided
to change the designs somewhat it was to
raise that level for the hms ganges
museum so it would accommodate the the
figurehead of course that's not the
overriding reason councilman can iron
asks about the people that are coming in
there it's been a mix we we know from uh
shotley lodge and from admiralty pier
that the mix is both um newcomers
sailors uh who have yachts in the marina
and obviously the big prevalence now is
people that don't want to work in london
all the time they work from home so
therefore they need a little bit more
space in those
apartments flats whatever you want to
call them
and that nine and three-quarter inches
helps enormously in terms of that
increase in that size
the need has been filled the both the
admiralty pier
all sold most of them off-site even
before they were completed same with
shortly lodge all sold
the change in the design to answer that
question
fits in with the two developments at um
at shortly lodge and abuti pier and uh
and possibly another one coming forward
as well um so that that's part of that
as well and actually i don't think the
the illustrations do do it justice
personally um
judging by the other two developers that
have been completed and filled so the
nine and three quarter inches hugely
important to hms ganges museum and of
course that has a knock-on effect to all
the others
the width you say with the lifts as well
making it more convenient the car
parking not only is there car parking
for the residents
i believe you're right i think it is 38
but i don't have that figure in front of
me but there's also a large car parking
um for the public as well to fit in and
and then a separate car parking for the
the the yacht holders the birth holders
at the marina
so i fully endorse
i think the officer's got this
absolutely spot-on it's been a bit of a
battle with historic england who didn't
actually come out there but
made their comments initially and then
they've changed it the applicant has
has done everything they can to make
this
an acceptable scheme and as has been
pointed out the permission has already
been granted it's just the other nine
and three-quarter inches that you're
giving a nod to
that's it thank you
any questions counselor beer um well i
would just like to thank councillor
davis because it's answered most of my
questions uh in what you just said it's
obvious that size does matter
and uh having said that um you've
explained the park and
i'm more than happy thank you
you have me i'll have the answer to the
parking question um
the scheme as shown on the submitted
documents um indicates
44 um spaces
plus three disabled spaces um in terms
of the standards would look at 225
provisions so two for each dwelling 25
a quarter of a space per dwelling for
visitor that which takes you to 42.75 so
it's it's slightly in excess of the
standards by one space plus three
disabled spaces
i'm very pleased here that so obviously
it's two
spaces per dwelling and we've got more
so it's the right direction but we could
have had more also but uh pennsylvania
says that we've got the additional car
parking for the museum so that would
help because out of hours i suppose that
could be used
all right
there's no more questions thank you
councillor davis
um
i'm now open the debate we only won't
like to start
counseling
well yes
um well certainly uh
we're
we've already approved this and this has
come back just for these minor
amendments um i i'm more than happy i
think um all that the concerns have been
addressed
yes i think i
did like to decided the original one
but i prefer the new one with the museum
bit added in there and shown because
that makes it look better so i'm more
than happy to recommend the uh to move
the officer's recommendation
for a second councillor parker give mr
speak
only just to concur with everything that
councilor beer has just said there
actually um yeah design um beauties in
the either beholder etc so we'll all
have a an opinion on that and at first
glance yeah the the original design
looks nice but um it's actually
relatively straightforward this one
chair so happy to second thank you
yes i just wanted to make a comment
chair
as a fellow member of
board member on chocolate peninsula
we welcome anything
that
brings tourists and
increases the income of the of the
peninsula and i i think this is a very
good scheme
so i just wanted to support it thank you
thank you council owen did you want to
fine
fine
no more comments
i will make comment um
as we're in debate
i have to say i think it's a shame that
the universal design has been
compromised to
to actually put in really quite an
ordinary looking block as opposed to
something that was actually quite
stunning in in that position it did sort
of
probably get through planning on the
basis that it was actually that sort of
design so i'm a bit disappointed i
understand fully that clearly costs you
know um come into this um but it is a
shame when we get
an initial design which is
very very
sort of
appropriate i think and uh marinerish
and then we get something which could be
anywhere but um
i don't feel strongly enough to vote
against it but i do feel that it's a
shame that these things come back and
then are compromised
thank you
thank you
yes thank you chair i totally agree with
um
the other councillors about approving
i'm not quite sure how long ago
um they were raped maybe derek um
councillor davis but
there are barriers all the way along the
king edward the seventh drive which is
much safer that access along there how
long has been that has made a big
difference
to access
um yeah it's it's possibly been about 10
years now it seems surprising but you're
absolutely right it was a nightmare
especially in the dark um and if you'd
had a couple at the shipwreck it was uh
extremely uh so the whole area has been
regenerated and
and and i would welcome uh councillor
barrett and others to come down and
actually have a look to see
what the developers have done so far
yeah
well no but you haven't seen how all the
changes because if you had you would see
shortly lodge and and admiralty pierre
the differences that that's made and
just if i may chair if indulge just
answered councillor beer's point about
the pier and
it's quite a distance away about 150
meters something like that but admiralty
peer development has um has done work on
their own pier not the shortly appear
that's a separate thing and and that
looks a lot better already and there's
still more to do than that but it does
it does look the whole front looks
better especially as you say with the
it's a lot of promenade now and radiance
and everything looks great
thank you
thank you
just to make sure that council davis
make sure i'm fully up to speed i have a
friend who's just bought number one
hadn't you and i had cocktails and
drinks looking over the port of harrich
and felix still thank you less than two
weeks ago
okay so um just to make sure you think
you're totally up to speed with what's
going on i don't think your social life
is part of a planning matter councillor
hinton
thank you thank you mr chairman just a
quick point of clarification really if i
could ask for one and that is that this
application is b stroke 13 when it was
approved which presumably means 2013.
um it was improved in or dated in 2016
which seems a bit of a long time to get
something that's been submitted to to
get it actually
put into the
right format
and the expiry date was the 26th of
february 2021.
so
is this a
an application due to the fact that the
original one has expired and has to be
redone
or or what what goes on there the
history is so complicated
it's a 73a
variation condition which means that the
commit the development has commenced
already that a means it has commenced
already
thank you
no if not i'll ask
claire to conduct the vote if you would
be surprised we have a
you're happy with the uh
publishing as
officer's recommendation yeah
thank you chair members that vote
is now in progress in your app
thank you
thank you chair that's 11 votes for
thank you
thank you very much um
i suggest we have a five minute break
before we take on the next application
and please man remind you this week we
are due out of here at 12 o'clock
thank you for turning me on
won't get back right
we're looking now at dc 2104 658 ram
between popkin road and raiden wave
great corner
i was at this stage ask councillors beer
and barrage whether they'll be staying
on the committee or talking as a ward
member
thank you conspiracy barrett
gradually thank you
thank you very much
right
moving on i'll ask elizabeth
is the flood to present the application
thank you chair uh so this is an
application uh for the erection of five
dwellings it's come to committee because
the applicant is weber district council
um you should be aware that we have
received a late representation which is
an objection due to the loss of open
space
so
this is the site
here it's on the corner of pot kiln road
along here
and uh
raiden way
along here this is stevenson
uh this is shawlands avenue along here
the main
road into this into the site uh and
you'll notice that it's a small area of
open space currently you'll also notice
opposite the site is a further area of
open space
with a mugger and some play equipment
uh that's another site location plan
so this is the site as it is it's
existing sort of uh informal access for
maintenance
and then these are the dwellings on pot
kiln lane on this end they are all
bungalows
and then this is the greater
area of great corner
uh
this is the constraints map as you'll
see this site in the local plan was not
designated as a
an open space
um
but um that was the case for them for
the majority of open space within great
carnard and
the urban areas
okay this shows the site layout
so it's a proposal for five
dwellings
five bungalows
two here and then a row of three here
they would all be um
two bedroom bungalows and they would all
be affordable tenure
um and you can see a small area of open
space would be retained with some
trees
and then this bit of open space next to
it would also be retained
now we will come back to the the
elevations and drawings of these
but one of the key issues is the loss of
open space
and the mppf does say you need to assess
whether if you're going to lose open
space
whether it's no longer required
so i just wanted to point out a few
things this is the site here
so it has this is the uh open space
assessment that's been recently
completed as part of the evidence base
for the
jlp
so it is
um this is a document that we know so we
have assessed these sites and you can
see opposite is the existing
recreation area with the
play equipment you'll also notice up
here is the
shawlin wood um nature reserve
now
this sets out the open space assessment
for great coronard and it does show a
deficit of uh 5.7
hectares of amenity open space
so if we lost this space that would be
another
further loss of open space
however the on on doing the openness
space assessment what it doesn't take
into account is the accessible natural
great green space which as you can see
great coronard has 27 hectares
um and that's um
you'll see there's two areas of um
accessible open uh green natural space
there's shawlands wood just along the
road from the site
and the great corner country park
so as though it looks initially like
this will further a loss of amenity
space
it should be taken into account that
there that this doesn't
include the
um this amenity space does not include
other space that is available
principally the um
the shorelands wood
just on the edge and also the fact that
the recreation ground
is opposite the site which provides much
better facilities so this is uh the
street scene so this would be plot five
four and three as you can see there the
bungalows with um
cars and
carports
again this is looking up the site uh
this is the boundary here so this is
plots three four and five the terrace
and then this is looking into the site
so this is plot one
curving round
these are the
elevations there's quite simple
bungalows um
to
fit in with what what there is existing
and then this is the sort of terrace of
three with the linked
detached ones
these are the
eleven floor plans so they're all
two bed
another two bed and then these
okay
so this is the site as it is so as you
can see it's this area of green space
there's a couple of smaller areas
within the edge
and this
this end here would be the open space to
provide a bit more um
to provide some landscaping
again this is looking to the site from
shoreline avenue you can see the
playground sign the playground is
literally on this side just opposite
and again this is looking from the
parking area of the playground through
the site onto the properties on pot kiln
right
pot kiln road so there they are
again this is looking at the site as you
can see it's just simple moan uh grass
it's got very little recreation value
it's got no facilities or seats or
anything
again that's looking up pot kiln road
with the site on the right you can see
the existing access
where the new access would be
again you can see that that access that
is used for a bit of informal parking at
the moment
and the site so this
um
hedging would be removed um but there
would be more hedging placed
again see the site this is from the
playground
and again this is looking up
um so this is a neighbor
this is the site behind these trees and
you can just see um the road curves
around like that and you can see the
mugger just there
and this is looking up pop kiln road you
can see the countryside at the end
and again this just shows you the
facilities this is literally on the
opposite side of the road so you can see
that there are
good recreational um facilities very
nearby
so the recommendation is for the um is
to grant planning permission thank you
thank you elizabeth
any questions for the officer
come to jameson
i think he's
um so if we're going to
get rid of this amenity space whether
it's used or not but we have we've been
through the correct process uh in the um
local government act to dispose of this
consulting with the public
um yeah in relation to a section one two
three of the local government act
it's that's not technically a planning
matter so we could give planning
permission without having to do that
because they're two separate legal
requirements
in addition at the moment the proposal i
understand is for the land not to be
disposed of it will be owned and managed
as council
housing but it won't be open space
anymore will it
yeah that's correct it won't be open
space
council beer
um thank you mr chairman i've got a few
questions first one can i ask history of
the site
um
i'm under the impression
that this site
came to us
about
10 years ago
around about that time
my memories go on as you get older um
sorry
i was at 1975 right
i accept that
but i seem to remember that we had a
um a public meeting in great corner
or
it might have been at the parish council
meeting that the hall became filled
because this was brought up now
did this plan and was there a plan and
application put in
i'm under impression there was and if so
there's no record here to the history
which concerns me i certainly when i
looked at the history from our system
which isn't perfect but we couldn't find
that i believe there was a proposal on
that site for some sort of um
units on there but i don't know whether
that actually came to fruition as in
terms of planning application
thank you yes i see that council that i
was born but the point i'm getting at is
that there there was a request to do
something on that site and it came to
and the locals were really uptight about
this this big public meeting went on
anyway i'll come back to that later but
you've answered my question so there was
that's that one now the other point was
on page 12
there under great conor parish council
baby discipline has pre-identified this
pocket of land as amenity green space
and it goes on um
i haven't seen a copy of this
is there one
of g
g c
o 20 in their ppg-17
[Music]
what's that all about
so that is a previous open space audit
that was done under the old ppgs so it
is a document that
was a previous document that's now been
overtaken by this um
by the the new um open space audit
that's been recently
undertaken
um thank you well i think that should
have been highlighted somewhere in the
report explaining that because um
you know that that does carry some
weight locally mr chairman
um right there was something else
do you want service anybody else yeah
councillor parker
yeah thank you chair um
and i think it's interesting um to note
uh elizabeth you mentioned the the email
that came in last night with regards to
the objection and and you mentioned that
the objection with regard to
the loss of amenity space so i actually
interpret that inject objection slightly
differently i actually think
um
overall it's an objection about process
that's been employed so i absolutely
take your point that um the the issue of
the s123 notices aren't material or that
they are material but they're not
necessarily um planning matters
but can you confirm or can anybody
confirm is there an intention to issue
an s123 notice can can that's that's the
first question can can you just tell me
bearing in mind that we've acknowledged
that this is amenity space as identified
in the open land assessment so if it has
been identified and you yourself said
that yes it will result in a loss of
community space even if it isn't
formally being disposed of do we intend
to follow due process and issue an s123
notice can you can you tell us
yeah counselor thanks i mean when you
say we obviously we we're the planning
authority and
they're the applicant we're doing it
like that sort of chinese walls so if
you've got any questions about that we
have a representative from the assets
team who can help with that
um but as far as we can it's like it's
like
if there was a covenant on the land and
it was a private applicant here's your
planning permission but if there's some
other arm of law that stops you doing it
then you can't do it you've got to sort
that out as well so they're two
different processes
i can be heard now
section one two three only um kicks in
or only applies if there's an intention
in the precise word is to dispose of the
land but disposal means
sell convey can by conveyance or grant a
lease or
tenancy other than a short tenancy it
would only be
applicable if one of those things
happened
not not applicable when a planning
application is made so that that's the
legal context you may wish to hear
further from someone else on the
practicalities
okay
well if i can respond to that thank you
mr
but but but i'm still unclear then um so
so categorically
is the process of issuing an s123 notice
applicable
categorically in this situation or not
and i think it's really important
because we've got to take this decision
and it has been highlighted and it is a
concern that i had thought about and and
how presto here is from from members of
the public so categorically do we need
to issue uh or does an a notice need to
be issued
there is no irregularity in this
committee make making a decision one way
or another or planning permission being
issued on the instructions of this
committee
without section one two three
uh being uh invoked that i can assure
you of that categorically
uh yeah yes um
that reminds me of a question um i
noticed here that um i think it said
somewhere there have been three
three letters um
written in
and
you've decided to take them as
objections
and i noticed on the last application we
just dealt with there was a letter which
the officers considered to be an
objection
now can you explain to me
if somebody writes in
and they disagree with what we're
proposing
that's got to be an objection surely why
is it that we've only had three when
i've had at least
a dozen people either phone me
stop me in the street
counselor newman in great corners has
a
tremendous amount of people going to his
shop concerned about it we've told them
all to write in and and
say what they think
and yet you're saying there's no
objections or there's three letters that
you
consider or objections well i'm sorry i
don't think you have a right to decide
that i think if somebody writes in as a
with an objection that should be
considered an objection can you please
explain yourselves on it so what we
categorize so say we got 10 letters in
someone will be object not for this just
for a planning application some will be
objections someone may be supporting and
some may just be a comment
and they sometimes people actually say
please do not take this as an objection
so what we do is we put all the so in
the reports we would put all the um
the letters we've got and then we would
say how many were objections how many
were for support so for this planning
application and i will i'm happy to
check if we've had anything recently i
know we had one more objection this this
this last night from from an email we
did only get free written objections
chair if i may
i've just checked the file accounts
appear there are three written
objections there may be people who
phoned up phoned you up in search but
only three people have written them
an extra one
so there's been four object well that
should have well obviously not the last
one but that should be made quite clear
in the paperwork again i think mr
chairman that there was three objections
because it made it read like there
wasn't
um
otherwise i think what you're
puzzling over is why the people who came
to you hadn't bothered to write in no
i accept what you're saying there i
think that i wish they had written in
no when i read this i expected to see
that you'd had letters of objections
from
10 residents or whatever and this hasn't
um and
when i read it there was no letters of
objection you decided that there was
some that you would take the subjections
and that didn't seem right to me thank
you
i think
answer him
thank you mr chairman uh mr duprey can
probably sort of
clarify this a bit
but
he came up with a load of reasons why
the one two three notice wasn't
applicable in his case because it wasn't
being disposed of etc etc but
where does denying access
by the public to an area come into those
regulations because effectively what
we're saying here is that a piece of
land that is owned by baber
which the public have free access to all
of a sudden it's going to become a piece
of land still owned by baber but the
public are denied access to it
entirely if i made sure and i entirely
take council hinton's point that it is
legally open to a council to take action
that have practical consequences which
may be um questionable or objectionable
to some people but it in this instance
it's not covered by section 123 which is
purely a
council as landowner or holder of
illegal interest disposing of its land
or giving somebody a lease or the legal
right over it um i mean as nothing i've
said so far should be seen to detract
from the right of objects as residents
to whoever to make a point about the
value of open space and it's within that
the weight of that factor for this
committee
wouldn't for one minute wish to
disrespect that point of view um
but it's not
uh my point i think is section one two
three i'm afraid is no assistance to
people in that situation as a not a
procedural requirement because
planning
is a as members i think are well aware
experienced members committee it's a
process that is separate from land
ownership although there may be a
practical link in nine out of ten cases
it's it's not that the two go go
separately
i could just just come back and say well
if if that is the case
uh the one two three noted the
regulation doesn't apply
uh presumably then paragraph eight point
two of the paper strategy on open spaces
does apply where it says existing
provision to be protected
uh starting point of any policy adopted
by the council should be that all open
space should be afforded protection
unless it can be proved it is not
required but to develop further from
that point
page
everybody all right i hope
at page 14 of the report paragraph 1.5
the site forms an area of proposed
designated open space in the regulation
19 submission of the draft joint local
plan
it then goes on on page 15 paragraph 3.6
to say draft joint local plan has not
yet been examined well i think it's in
the process of being examined which
significantly reduces the weight which
can be maybe afforded to it well
we all know that planning can be a very
opaque business
and it's certainly not clear in black
and white terms but this is getting
beyond anything it's almost as if we're
mixing it up to start off with before we
even come to any discussion on
it council hidden was that a question to
someone or or no
okay
we'll move on council parker you've had
your hands up sometime
yeah thank you well that that then goes
on actually just to expand on on what
counselor hinton is saying um because
again in in
the the letter of objection that's come
in mention of um nppf para99a is
mentioned and that is
that's not opaque that is absolutely
clear existing open space sports and
recreational buildings and land
including playing fields should not be
built on unless an assessment has been
undertaken which has clearly shown the
open space buildings on land to be
surplus so
um i i think elizabeth i think it was
slide seven you you showed a table and a
graph of of land and i i think but i
need clarification on it i think what
you're saying is is that despite the
assessment having been taken which does
clearly show the open space um
um
is is going to be built on that there is
uh available i can't read it available
green space
because you are showing a deficit there
so
so we do need clarification 99a is
absolutely clear um if if we use 99a
we're surely with this application we're
in convention of that are we not
i think there are a few things one thing
is the definition of open space within
the nppf
and whether this land does come under
that definition because
of
um you know the fact that it is very
informal recreational land um
secondly
i think it also comes down to whether we
can you consider whether that um
that space is surplus to requirements
and i think that's based on a few things
not just the fact that it's
it's open space it's whether it's
actually used as open space the quality
of it and whether there's alternatives
so as i've shown there is an alternative
use you know there is a playground
literally opposite the site which
probably will mean that the recreational
value of this land is
is much less than it would be if there
wasn't a playground opposite because
people are more likely to you know go
and play in the playground with the
proper facilities than play on a piece
of grass
equally there is other
in terms of the
assessment yes when you look at it
immunity green space there is a deficit
and this would increase the deficit so
if you look at it purely on that basis
yes we're making this situation worse
but what that that open space assessment
doesn't take into account the is the
amount of accessible natural green space
within great corn art and i think what's
particularly relevant for this
application is the shorelines wood which
is literally
you know 100 meters 200 meters from the
site so
that is 27.28
worth of hectares overall that hasn't
been included if you added that you'd
probably find that
the deficit
i mean it wouldn't be as simple as just
adding it to amenity green space because
the immunity green space has other
values that the accessible natural green
space doesn't have but in terms of
strictly recreational value as opposed
to
landscape value or or you know value as
a small area of green space then
that would be more than covered by the
amount of accessible natural green space
there is within the parish
thank you chair
um
in the
comment by the parish council
which nobody's mentioned so far and to
me is quite important
is the availability for an air ambulance
to land in an emergency
now in my book that is quite an amenity
for the um people of cornard
if we approve this application were you
planning to offer some alternative land
in space looking at the site
and
there is plenty of room for rotary
blades to operate of a helicopter
were you going to offer cornered another
site so the air amblers could use that i
think it's important for the people of
cornard
and
i'd be interested in that elizabeth
thank you no we weren't going to um
provide another site because
it's not really a statutory thing it's
i mean and we accept that yes the loss
of this site would mean that probably
the nearest site for the air ambulance
to land would be the stevenson's center
and therefore if there was an incident
closer to this area
there would be a problem and like the
parish has said but ultimately
it is only an emergency
so
it would have to be an emergency that
happened in that vicinity as opposed to
anywhere else where they would land
elsewhere such as the stevenson center
now
and
and so we have no
known knowledge of how many times that
happens
the air ambulance itself is a charity it
could shut it's not a statutory
requirement to have an air ambulance
so
it's it's something that's quite
difficult to provide a space for
something that
is infrequent and you you'll need to
weigh that up against the value of the
land as as as affordable housing
i just think it's um
looking at the site you can understand
why it was chosen by the air ambulance
because if you're looking at the other
green spaces
in corner there probably isn't the
the width of space for the road rotors
to go around and that that is really
important thank you
yeah um i'll just pick up elizabeth's
point about the uh the fact that there's
play equipment i think the trouble is
though
the the the site as an open space an
amenity
is very popular and used by people who
walk dogs and things so
it's the fact it's an open space
and not designated for any particular
reason is actually why it is used as it
is used
you are actually surrounded there with a
and if you can this is the question it
is a very dense
populated area so any open space for
people with dogs that's important they
don't just use
clay equipment and that's where i think
the amenity element is is there so i
think
your point about the um player equipment
is valid
but clearly
open space is not just about play
equipment
would you agree
yeah we accept that it will involve a
loss of of wreck of amenity land and
it's probably is
if you know what it is probably used for
is dog walking but it is
not recreation it's probably less used
as recreation land for things like
informal sports because if you're going
to kick a football around you're much
more likely to go opposite to the mugger
than to to use this piece of land
thanks to jameson
thank you
away from the loss of the green space um
i don't see any mention of the
environment or the sustainability
credentials of these
um
bungalows in the report we building them
better than
um
required standards
in terms of planning we would only
require the the building reg standards
but um i understand that the agent is
here and they might be able to give you
some more information about anything
they've done above that
right thank you we'll move on and see if
we get some more information that may
help everyone
public speakers
there is no parish council
representative
no objector
or a supporter
all we have is the agent and councillor
osborne is going to address the
committee for one minute and lucy
smith's gonna fill within the two
minutes afterwards
council osborne
thank you mr chairman morning chairman
members as written for the point of
order why is councillor
jan husband
addressing the committee for one minute
and in what capacity is she addressing
this committee
we had some discussion before the
meeting about the precise probity of
everything and councillor osborne is
essentially the applicant because she's
the cabinet member for housing and she
an applicant speaks or they have an
agent in this case the applicant and the
agent are sharing the three minutes if
i've that that's the conclusion we
reached isn't it which is
not not giving the council any more
advantage than another landowner would
have
thank you
thank you
as referred to on page 13 of your report
there is a significant demand for
affordable rented properties in great
cornard
with a hundred entries on the register
with a local connection
21 of which are aged over 55 and 14
require an adaption to aid mobility
problems
yes there are some concerns raised which
i fully understand and i visited the
site yesterday to take a look however
the balance is that there are a lot of
people in need of a place they can call
home and that they can afford
if members are of a mine to approve this
application i would like to ask them to
consider adding a condition that at
least three of the five dwellings are
allocated as a local connection
hi um my name's lucy smith planner in
gothenwood i'm speaking on behalf of the
applicant so thank you for
the opportunity to let me speak today
so the application has been submitted as
part of the wider affordable housing
strategy which includes the
redevelopment of some council owned
sites
and baber and mid-suffolk councils have
an acute need for affordable housing and
so there is a significant demand for
affordable rented properties in great
corners specifically as mentioned
um bungalows are particularly suitable
to cater for
for um many of the people on this list
you get a little bit closer to the
microphone yep sorry i can hear you
clearly but not everyone can yeah and as
you've heard um the proposed development
comprises of five new affordable rent
bungalows with associated parking and
landscaping including an area of open
space to the west the proposed dwellings
meet the nationally described space
standards and sit in generously sized
plots by virtue of the the nature of the
site and the existing established
boundaries there would be no adverse
impact on amenity of the existing or
future residents in terms of highways
adequate visibility is provided and no
concern has been raised by suffolk
county councillors highway authority
um it is acknowledged that the existing
site presents an area of
green amenity space however the proposal
has been designed designed to be over
lower density single stories only and to
deliberately retain a section of open
space with specimen trees limiting the
overall visual impact
in this location where there is formal
recreational area and open space in
close proximity the significant
sustainable outcome of the affordable
housing benefit is considered to
outweigh any impact on the local
character
in terms of the the government act which
has been mentioned i don't want to sort
of repeat any of the points that have
been raised
um but
yeah so currently we we would dispute
this sort of as the it's not considered
that the land's been disposed of and but
the applicant has been made aware of
this and obviously seek
and sort of diligent legal advice to
confirm this
thank you
answer beer you have a question uh yes
my ken my question is to counselor
jan osborne
thank you thank you um normally
uh
when we build a council dwellers they're
available to anybody in weber district
is that correct
it depends on the agreement of the 106
on how those properties are going to be
allocated for example the ones recently
in shockley they were um three were
given up for local connection and the
other ones were for babel wide
my question was that normally
they are not
necessarily just for local people
only if otherwise requested yes and
which is what you've done at the 11th
hour
asked enough now to consider approving
this and you will give the people of
great cornard three
dwellings which are small bungalows i
think that is really blackmail mr
chairman if if we went down that road
then all values should be given to the
people of great colonia
yes there was a question
and
so can you give all five
if you can as i said in my in my bit
that um i would suggest at least three
but if you want to go with five by all
means you can do that it's not at the
last 11 hour that's to be agreed at a
later stage with the 106 agreement
thank you how much um communication have
you had with the parish council
and the people around that area please
i wouldn't have had that that would be
down to the planning offices and the
agent i wouldn't have done that and it
would have been part of the consultation
of the application itself
can someone answer the question then how
much
yeah
whoever wants to answer it so um
i do know that the the parish council
was made aware of the application before
it was submitted
i'll come back on that one please and we
always ask this question but how many
how much communication have you had with
them have you sat down have you talked
to them
about what you want to do in the parish
of cornell please
sorry no no it's just the letter in this
case
thank you chair and um uh it's it's lucy
isn't it yeah thank you lucy um you
mentioned in your presentation that
there would be um no uh impact on
immunity um but i i might question that
lucy actually um because i'm looking um
on the on the plans here i'm looking at
the entrance
and i think if you live at number 81 i
think you will be severely impacted
actually by cars coming and going and
i'm just wondering if it's possible to
get there was an image of a car that was
parked on a bit of land and i think it
was suggested that that would be the
entrance but
um
we'll see in just a second
yeah
right yeah there you go right now i
would suggest to you that that is not
where the uh where the entrance is shown
on the uh on the on the description at
all um the description of the the
entrance as per
the the uh the drawing um on the you
know on the planning application itself
is more towards that hedge if we can go
back to the car
with that side we were just on
yeah right so i would suggest looking at
the um looking at the drawing that's on
the uh on the planning application
actually the entrance is going to be
right on the edge of that hedge and so
therefore all of the traffic that's
going to be coming and going out of that
development the headlights are actually
going to go straight into the ground
floor well they're bungalows but um but
the the the windows of number 81 across
so actually i think if the entrance
could be where that car is and this way
a little bit um i i think you would do
away with the uh with the immunity so
i'm just wondering if um
um you know if that is if that is a
possibility because where it's where
it's shown i'm looking at that diagram
there um counsellor um
where that shown is not where that car
is
in my opinion
okay um
yeah i think so the design utilizes it
it's not not exact same position i agree
but it does utilize that existing hard
standing um for the access
um we don't consider in this design that
that would have a significant impact on
amenity giving sort of the distance
i don't think sort of
the in terms of headlights right so if
if i could just share if i could um if i
could come back to that and i i
appreciate you you might not agree with
that lucy but we you know we as the
committee have got to take the decision
we might think differently um and if
that's the case i just think because
actually i i'm i don't actually object
to um to the principle of what we're
trying to do here i have got some issues
around the process um and i have got to
you know i just think to myself we're
the landowner
why would we impose uh a
you know a reduction of immunity on
residents if we don't have to so i i'd
be much happier if i thought that we
might be able to move that driveway
around a little bit but um anyway
i'll come back to debate on that chair
thank you
thank you chair um hi
uh yeah could you give me some details
on the environmental credentials in
terms of carbon reduction
and renewables place
yep so um this scheme doesn't currently
um propose any renewable energy sources
um sort of as mentioned it's not not
required
for a scheme of this size but but we do
um
with these schemes
uh we take a fabric first approach so
maximizing in terms of materials and
components
and to ensure sort of the performance as
um
the performance of the dwelling sort of
keeps energy levels low in first
instance which
can have a reduction
so so we um going just as far as
building control or going beyond that
um i think it's
generally beyond that in terms of
insulation but obviously we wouldn't
have submitted that information with the
planning application
okay thanks
thank you chad um i was interested to
see that the nearest space where a
helicopter could land would be at
stevenson center maybe i'm wrong but i
would have thought the playing field at
popkill and school would have been
closer
do we have any evidence of the distance
thank you
i don't think so is the
answer um i'm sorry i'm i'm not sure
about about that um because because they
don't have a particular landing
locations as far as i'm aware
um
yeah i'm not sure exactly how they
choose that
i do know the school quite well and it's
quite a large field and a playground
which i would hope if there was an
emergency could be used thank you
i
i think that we have we have the
situation where the officers said that
providing something for the the air
ambulance is is very difficult because
we don't know what the air evidence will
be there there tomorrow so whereas
the implication is that there is a need
for housing now
particularly bungalows cancer beer would
you agree with
thank you
any more questions
no right well open it up for debate
council beer
thank you
i'm going to start by saying yes
i accept
bungalows are needed throughout the
district and we need them in great corn
are because we have lots of houses and
not enough bungalows
but
i'll come back to that later this isn't
the place
first of all there's been quite a few
comments made about the air ambulance
i'll try and pick up some of them i
think the pot kiln school if i remember
rightly they're acquiring or trying to
get permission to
infill the swim pool area and enlarge
that so they might encroach a bit more
onto that playing field so that wouldn't
be large enough
secondly the stevenson center which we
did have the air ambulance land on
recently when there was the fire at the
brook hotel in greek brook pub in greek
horner
um it landed there
but the
emergency services to get to the
recreation field the steams and center
you have to sort of encounter a little
one-way system so it takes longer
and it would take longer
the field they use at the moment despite
the fact and i accept what you're saying
mr chairman and the officers that
it could be gone tomorrow it's been
there now for 10 years the air ambulance
and i think that most people will do
everything to make sure that that keeps
flying so i think that's really a red
heron
that is a place where it could land
quite easily um
the the area users now and it is
important because
the road
there
is the quickest connection
to the um colchester berries and edmonds
road either way you can go and you can
get to that very very quickly from the
area where you're proposing to put these
bungalows
so i would ask members to bear that in
mind um
i i want to say about the
the residents that live up there i think
there was a slide which show the amount
of bungalows um along there if you could
just find it i i've made a note of so
many slides that's pointless uh not that
one
not that one
it's it's more like an area of shot of
the houses that are already there
go back one yeah now there's 26
houses
bungalows
they're mostly bungalows opposite and
are behind the site going up
their bungalows and houses
now the mix of those people that live
there the residents i would say um
be very careful here and not being
disrespectful to anybody
they must be
in the later age group 50 plus so it's
predominantly an area of of older
population and members should remember
that great corners population
is towards ten thousand
it's the second largest populated area
in baby district council larger than
hagley and
where this particular site is is right
in the
middle the center part of the massive
council housing estate that was proposed
in the 1960s and 70s formerly known as
the glc which we now call assurance
most of those houses there that you can
see
were council owned a lot of them are
sold now but a great majority of them
are council
owned
we've heard reference and the reason why
i'm now jumping a little bit to
shorelands wood
which is further along there it's a good
200 meters away from here i would say
nearer three
but uh that land
i believe was county council
and they gave that to the parish
councils in um
holden with the parish council as uh um
shawlands would uh
what do you call it for
nature reserve that's the word and thank
you
um and so that that was their help
the um
stevenson center belongs and the
recreation ground
belongs to great corner parish council
we have a lot of area down blackhouse
lane
which is a public play and fields
belonging to great corner parish council
you've referred to the country park
that also belongs to great cornard
parish council
the allotment field
which is a large site that also belongs
to great corner parish council on behalf
of the public of great corner
very little
has been given by baby district council
very little
of uh park uh play areas and amenity
area
great art is provided
it's the greatest amount of amenity area
than i would say any other village
and and
to have this imposed upon them i don't
think is right
because
this area is an open space and i think
council barrow did question the point
that whilst it isn't used for say a
football game or a match and things like
that because of the play area just
across the road bearing in mind that is
more for 14 year olds
there is some small player equipment
there but people tend to go on this
little bit of a land uh with small
children they'll kick a little ball
around i've seen and what have you yes
dog walkers do use it
i think also somewhere it said that you
would be taken out the hedge
that goes up
along um
the pot kiln road and you'd be replacing
that by putting it the other side on the
roadside the main bit of roadside um
well that will spoil that that sort of
area with the visual impact and i don't
think that's that's good at all
um
certainly the residents
and they come from far worried in great
corn i'd have stopped me and contacted
me that they think this is appalling to
get do away with this last little oasis
of tranquility that we've got there in
great corner because
if you put up that plan that you just
had a moment ago
i think it was 22
you can see
all around this
it is a buttered by houses with densely
populated
and whilst we have that little play area
opposite which we had to fight hard to
get favor to
put in equipment there and what have you
um
we've got this little open space
the locals believe this is um protected
and that it would be there for all time
um and your talent is that you don't
have to implement a one two three on it
and other things i think the lack of
communication has been very poor
um
there should have been discussions but
the general feel and from everybody and
their unanimous that this
is not acceptable
and that we shouldn't allow it uh we
shouldn't impose this here in great
cornard um there are an immense amount
of development that have gone on
recently
in great corner to the tune of i should
say of nearly a thousand additional
houses uh in the last
10 years
and here you are wanting to use up this
little piece of land and it is a small
area right in the center
um i think it's the portland
but i may want to come back mr chairman
well i think there's a number of things
issues there um
we can't take
unfortunately council of beer's word
that everybody is unanimously against it
well even that we've had three people
that have written in and three people
have objected and that's what we have to
take on into account
as for the helicopter i can't believe
we've ever discussed
landing space for a helicopter in any
other planning application ever
a bit so i'm a bit surprised it's taken
up um
so significant thing here
um as for
uh lay your traffic at night from the
site for the bungalows i presume we were
talking about five bungalows here
predominantly likely to be for elderly
people i can't believe there'll be more
than one or two cars going and out of
there at night it's not it's not
although it's going to be the m25
so i don't think that's an issue
if you if you could put that slide back
up where you show the land in the uh
what is that
to the to the north east where it says
slide four is that open space or are
they houses up there
it's open land what's that about 150
meters away or 100 meters away
well in that case
that as part of that development we need
to make sure that there is sufficient
open space
i think we're making
a bit of a mountain out of a moulding on
this one uh personally
thank you council adversary
anyone else council reyes
thank you chair um i tend to agree with
councillor busby um about the helicopter
issue um we've not raised that before
um there is a real need for bungalows as
often councillors do ask for and i'm
sure that they will be built with all
the new conditions
ecology has been addressed
with the replanting things like that
and i don't think this area would have
been used for ball games with my
grandchildren i wouldn't plant a bit of
grass that hasn't got fencing around it
because you can guarantee the balls will
go in the road
um and so and they will plant new hedges
so i am for the development thank you
okay
parker
yeah thank you chad um
i it's really tricky this one because i
i absolutely understand the need um to
supply housing
for me it does hinge on policy um for me
and i
i understand in respect of designating
open space etc that the difficulty for
me is is that in this particular case
we own the site we are the applicant but
we have identified in our own open
assessment uh open space assessment that
this is open space
and
para99a of the mppf is absolutely clear
about that that you won't build on it so
there's the tension um now is there such
a significant public benefit
as to be able to support it it really is
uh it really is borderline i mean i i've
i've called on a boy live lived in
corner born and raised in cornard on pot
hill road i never ever not once did i
ever play on that piece of land and i
will just come back to the air ambulance
me personally i'm not saying that it
doesn't land but it doesn't it doesn't
land frequently there it absolutely
doesn't so i think actually for a
different reason i think it's a red
herring but for policy reasons
i'm really struggling to be able to
support this um chair thank you
thank you guys parker council mclaren
thank you
well listening to all the dismissive
comments about the air ambulance um
perhaps it's never come up before but
that doesn't mean to say it's relevant
and i think it is an amenity for the
people of great cournot
um
the comments about it being a charity
and about to go out of business
is immaterial
50 of our social services are run by
charities so the fact it's got
charitable status i think is
an onstarter but i think it is an
amenity that they've got
and i think it would be a shame to lose
it
just to come back on that point of the
air ambulance i can assure you i have
known of two occasions recently where
the air ambulance has landed on that
piece of ground
and the third occasion was when they
landed on the recreation ground um for
the the last fire um but
and to suggest that we've never brought
it up in any other application we most
likely haven't because the perhaps it
hasn't risen but i can assure you in
this large populated area
um the air ambulance that is the only
place that can really realistically land
and
we should bear that in mind
thank you
any other comments from anyone
counseling
yes mr chairman um
i agree with certain opinions that the
air ambulance is a bit of a of a red
herring but at the same time
this is designated
open space under regulation 19
in the submission to our draft local
plan
um the plan is being looked at at the
moment and to say that it hasn't got any
reduces and significantly reduces the
weight that may be afforded to it
is a bit
spurious when you consider that
virtually every week we are submitting
new documents to support the local plan
uh without any formal consultation with
anybody but they seem to be appearing
like um
moles in your garden when you've got a
pristine lawn um but
we've got a deficit of open space within
great corn art
we've got a
policy which says that we shouldn't get
rid of open space unless it's proved to
be not required we've seen no evidence
at all to say that
that has been
established
so i'm afraid i'd have to go along with
the people who say that this this
application cannot be supported in its
current form
council baron do you want to come in
yes oh um
right um
i'm very much
in a dilemma over this because i
would normally um support this
application with
gusto in terms of
five affordable housing and especially
bungos bungalow pete to my left is
obviously
highly supportive of any bungalow as we
all know
um
but
the problem that we have got and i take
councillor parker's point and i think
this is the issue if this was uh what i
would call an open market application as
opposed to the district council
application if i went to the planners
and said i would like to build five
bungalows on a piece of
land that's been designated as amenity
land
the pre-application advice i get would
probably be no you can't build on that
because it's community land
and i think that's where we fall in the
stall so i mean there is an advantage
and there's a benefit to our community
in terms of five houses but equally are
we not being uh uh
balanced in our view if we were to take
the view oh well the need outside
because it's us coming forward with
social housing and i think that's the
dilemma that probably council parker my
father sells
i i on one hand i can totally understand
the requirement and and the need but
equally when i look at the map and we've
seen it on there
it is a very dense
part of great corn art
it has very
high levels of social housing to one
side
they do not have a lot of open space
that is open space now regardless of
whether the use of that open space but
sometimes you've got to say we're all
talking about mental health we're all
talking about you know being restricted
or being stuck inside
and to be able to go out and maybe just
stand in the middle of that open space
and let the rain come down on top of you
gosh it sounds like a film um
but that is important
i know
the chairman has raised his eyebrows
because obviously he lives in clemson
which has plenty of open space and it
never rains so um
but i do feel that
on balance and this is the key thing on
planning balance
i think i would have to say
and also having had representation from
many members of uh great corner i think
on my planning balance would come down
uh to say i do not approve of the
application in its current state
and i would propose
that we move uh to
go against that with the recommendation
that paragraph 99 a takes priority
fine
any other comments
may i just make a couple of points okay
um just just so to
some members confirm their opinion
um we've had the discussion about the
open space um glossary to the mppf
describes it thus um
open spaces all open space of public
value including not just land but water
which offer important opportunities for
sport and recreation and can act as
visual amenity
so what one could take the view that it
falls under that category i think it's
probably the lower end of the quality
off but it's you know you could say it
falls under that category
um in which case we do have to look at
what was 97 in my mppf it's now 99
which shows that you should not build on
such land unless
and i think 1999 as is important when it
talks about the assessment
our assessment shows that there is if
you include all the informal green space
around
quite a surfeit of open space
um
and with the corner tie development
coming up that will provide another six
hex hairs or albeit that is the
proportionate to what it should be
that's that's the ten percent
um so
you could take the view that the
assessment
allows us to
allow the development if you want to
so at that point
you then have to
look at his planning merits
you have to weigh up the loss and the
gain
sorry chair oh sorry counselor council
plum
i spear you okay can i add in also that
the the the the loss of the
amenity
open area call it what you want uh
outweighs
the benefits that you you have suggested
so that members i think is the judgment
you have to make if we accept that by
the wording of the mppf we can find an
argument to allow it because we've done
what we should do we're now on to the
assessment
and councillor barrett made a point
about
us only being positive to this because
it's a council application i'm aware of
that as an argument i think we have to
be aware of that
i think two things to say um
obviously it's just going to be
affordable housing so there's no
it's not like a private developer
profiting from it it's for the good of
the community in that sense
and the other thing to say is if it was
a private developer and this is a
private open space
how will we balance that so we have to
consider our application as if as if it
were a third party like in that sense we
have to be
not too
not too um permissive but not too unfair
so you really have to just weigh up the
things in front of you
um and i think probably the
[Music]
the plus point we have to look at is the
supply of affordable housing we've got
100 plus people on the register i think
um councillor osborne said that and this
provides five dwellings um
which we
can look to tie to local need i need to
speak to affordable housing about that i
think we do it by condition anyway
because it's
a council project so we don't have to
get to into 106s we can just do it by
condition
so those would appear to be the the
benefits and i understand that you see
some disk benefits so if the focus could
be on that and ambulances noted but i
don't i wouldn't want to find an appeal
on that argument i just we have to put
that to one side no i wouldn't expect
you to fight an appeal
yeah thank you very much indeed
listening to that with with interest and
that um because in paragraph 99a it says
an assessment has been undertaken which
clearly shows under open space buildings
or land to be surplus to requirements
it then goes on to say in b the loss
resulting from the proposed development
will be replaced by equivalent or better
provision in terms of quality and qual
quantity and quality are in a suitable
location
we haven't done any of those we're not
propo if that had been a private
developer we'd be saying we want some
open space
it just says or it's it's not it doesn't
be all of those has to be it's
all or
but we haven't done anything to assess
it so it's a country to um to
policy you know so does the proposal
go along with you
that was the benefit of the the loss of
the immunity area outweighs any benefits
okay
any other issues in great corner that
needs time spent on like anti-social
behavior and park and areas
thank you um
yes chair i mean obviously yeah it feels
like we've we have to we've got 17
minutes unless we think we can't do it
today um we're moving towards a vote um
we need a discussion about
if
well sorry first of all we go forward do
we agree with the officer we'll do that
first and if that falls then we'll have
to talk about what we do next
all right so so your proposal and second
at the moment is is to to
to reject the officers
so we have opposed the second though
you're all happy to go to a vote
sorry we're proposing to refuse are we
yes sure um sorry could i have some
headlines for that just just for private
basically
so
your reasons for refusal please
okay um
i i would suggest chair if we're saying
that it falls foul of that part of the
mppf i think i've given an answer which
suggests it doesn't
um if you want us to go away and come
back another time to say well you think
that's not the case we can do that
it is yes um
i don't know whether the assets
representative is able to add any more
to this point sorry to put you under no
you haven't got any off okay so we're in
a situation chair where the councillors
feel that that assessment has not taken
place adequately
absolutely and that seems to be
informing the reason for that yes also
that of course it's contrary to
regulation our regulation 19 submission
to the joint local plan and also
contrary to the um
when i can find the
the screen here i wouldn't go the jlp
still i heard what you said about that
8.2 of the paragraph 8.2 of the babur
mid-suffocating space assessment which
shows the deficit of land in court
in corner not the jlp council it's still
got limited weight
um and i know it's getting a bit boring
for a long time but it still has got if
we have a look in our own local plan
we'll find something about open space in
there
okay i'm sure you that
at the moment
we have a proposal
and the second
let's put that to
vote and you have reasons for that but
the reason is that um
an adequate assessment hasn't taken
place as per paragraph 99 of the mppf um
i've heard suggestions also about jlp
which i'll advise against
and also our own open space um
you had the two points you made
that cover them
does that cover the the the point that
i've made that uh the benefits don't
outweigh the loss of amenity area
because quite often you say to us yes
but we have to have this what there's
about so you're saying
you can you can have that as your second
reason aware of timing so normally we'd
break away and get the wording for you
if we can agree
the headlines you'll have to leave us to
do the crafting
i'm just going to look towards the legal
representative that's
ian
okay okay so we're going with the fact
that the paragraph 99 hasn't been
complied with
and beyond that looking at the planning
balance the loss of a space is not
outweighed by the public benefits
council councillor parker did bring out
and quote those and i wasn't quick
enough to write them down but uh he did
quote that why he felt that that time
that he may not be able to support yeah
that's fine it's just getting getting a
feeling to what your proposal is which
people will now vote on yeah we have
that proposal and now we'll take it to a
vote the vote should now be available
for you
thank you chair members that vote is now
in progress
counselor beer
thank you chair that's eight votes for
refusal and three against
okay
you okay
fine
thank you very much
uh the next meeting will be on
the 30th
3rd of november
and
don't forget
site visit
next week
you